boom rose my name is beard look at all
this period Jesus Christ someone really
freaking huge she made this probably
like a dinosaur period or something I
would just assume oh [ __ ]
he's right there save me lap all right
we're gonna do with pit oh I got it can
walk here I was gonna say we're gonna do
the pillar walk but
Oh is he coming over here hello
he can't see me right I mean there would
be a sound if you could hear me
oh [ __ ] I don't trust him he's damn good
looking now oh oh the [ __ ] lamb
scared me what mr. champ
I should do I can't believe I still
don't have my lantern I still AM we had
the [ __ ]
I mean puss and I don't know I cried
quite frankly I don't know I think we
have to go over here again and do our
stuff and that thing is gonna chase me
oh but yep gotta change me cuz I grew up
I'm chasing you down you're gonna go to
waited yet it's so creepy cuz I get hot
why are you okay okay we're good we're
good
I don't think we're good I mean we could
be good Jesus Christ so loud it sounds
like it Boop alright Oh is he in here
are you kidding me give me a [ __ ]
break
I'm just gonna follow the gist as usual
Paulie was it just usually works all my
nose work bro I don't appreciate that
bro oh boy he's like follow the gist
doesn't work but my mom was a [ __ ]
liar
she's like follow just spitting I like
just [ __ ] killed me bro killed me I
only do that I just went oh no yeah I
had no choice I can't escape displays
Bertha chambered in my position in life
and no option but to sell them and to
offer them sacrifice sometimes I wonder
what is my fate to become their servant
or saying the intention of something
else okay there's supposed to be a
freaking body here somewhere oh no no
bro
it's so dark why oh it's there
follow the gist row what did they do to
you all right we gonna stab this guy no
don't worry you're gonna stab you I
don't care I need your heart bro I
probably lied to me maybe it's penis I'd
be awesome if I could cut off his penis
all right [ __ ] oh that plan failed
pretty hard horribly
so the bro just before he died he like
ah finished kissing this one likes and
then he killed himself I wouldn't make
sense I mean if I were a bro I would do
that now we're talking about I am broke
well it's not good for anyone
anyway stop Jesus Christ Oh someone
there
I know anyone I swear it wasn't me I
just follow the gist
it's got done this modest creepiest for
Rican penises everywhere
all right I'm kind of freaking stuck we
have a rustic evil I don't know where
that goes
I this investigate father over here I'm
just saying it could be interesting I
mean I'm like Jennifer wow this is gang
banging with Jennifer's I'm taking you
with me
oh you're damn fine no I'm not gonna do
that all right what's there huh oh no oh
no where you see you see upstairs
no I don't I don't know I heard up
lizard the one I'm missing maybe make me
not probably not where is he oh there he
is but it wasn't him I don't get it it
was you bounce wasn't it
bounce bounce I hate you all right what
about here
No
huh oh [ __ ] it really is him holy penis
maybe opens the door for me sit Peggy
what are you doing
Josh stop all right
this is shared seeing anybody oh [ __ ]
you really it's a pity I'm gonna be
surge ready it's bad [ __ ] either pick
me up on this chair all right I just
want to go in here maybe I can use
Sakina maybe I can stab mr. chair maybe
mr. Sherr want some [ __ ]
yes very pushy I mean push I'm just
kidding I prefer shares
I don't like regular vaginas I'm not
gear anything but I'm a share all right
do you subscribe you got to realize I
did that by the way oh yes I'm in heaven
okay whatever what is this broken box
I don't know what he wants this is what
struttin that ass maybe I need to go
here all right
and that go where though I can't not
like it to go back I can unlock it to go
back to see if I miss something
why would that be I don't know if I miss
something that I missed something bras
I'm kind of lost from here right now not
sure what you gonna do
hmm this is difficult difficult it's a
big map it's Big Mac I don't miss any
keys I'm pretty damn sure
then you bros would be you mr. cute it's
obvious it's it's not obvious of those
things doesn't respawn oh god it's a
spider oh I miss my eyes are spiders yes
all right listen actually miss something
holy [ __ ] all right three spider legs
Jane push my own blood cut up a human
heart that's difficult where can I find
a human heart maybe I make the bro kill
himself that'd be awesome
I can't go ahead all right fine fine
I'll go back then oh no actually never
mind
oops all right I think I got all I need
I mean I and you know how human heart
maybe I should cut off my own heart
no that would be bad for everyone okay I
think I'm gonna try to make the broke
himself how should you make it bro kill
himself
this is a genius idea maybe falling down
the well like the ring something creepy
have you guys seen the ring I I haven't
seen it I remember I saw him when I was
like 13 and I just saw I saw the
beginning where their faces get all
fired up and I was like nope Wow
watching this one
and then then I watched the ring - a
couple days ago and it wasn't that bad
huh oh don't against me bro I think I
need it heart I need your heart bro
maybe we can make him chase us after
what do you think battery situation mr.
share said I wrath on you what is that
thing on you mr. chair mr. chair stand
up sign up when I'm talking to you
alright okay the plan here mr. Chou I'm
gonna go go okay this is serious
business mr. Sherr we're gonna throw you
Adam now don't throw me bits please at
least we're not brush okay I don't know
I don't even know anymore
and Cal lose his bait go mr. sharp yeah
yeah Betty chairman accurate
it didn't work how about some boxes
okay this is me all right come on oh
okay let's go
all right hopefully that thing kills him
or something out of it stop
come on oh my son is so [ __ ] low he's
coming away
rah rah rah never like very good or what
little bit it's not joining
Jesus Christ is pushy I mean I'm
[Applause]
hmm I thought that thing would step in
but it didn't it's weird it always steps
in you know I don't know how to mimic
that sound something like that oh god my
son is so long [ __ ] am i doing
oh the bro is back [ __ ] you bro well I
was kidding
well save me mr. champ
what is he Oh was awesome
okay I hope he's not behind me I hope
it's not behind even this don't be
behind me please don't be behind me oh
thank god
I thing is not chasing me anymore I
don't get I don't get it quite frankly I
don't get preventing the door for an
opening all right so I can't go back
there
I need the human heart it's still a dark
building it's so dark I thought so dark
pity so why don't I get someone said I
should cut it out from the bow and I
thought that sounded pretty good idea
but if [ __ ] thing won't worry I mean
I found the dagger next to the row I'm
just gonna go out oh I want to go all
the way taking my [ __ ] ladder and
kid-safe ladder jump
maybe two got killer shopping I mean it
disappeared pretty quickly should we do
bro what should we do with you maybe if
the bro and they kill each other maybe
hit did some oh no not again bro can I
say all this is horrible
okay let's just go to the word of the
bro was all right look I in there bro I
just want to stab his heart out because
I have the whole ingredients hey bro hey
in here alright here we are again bro
have damn fine arm there why you know
work I just want y'all stupid Hawk beard
shut up alright
[ __ ] I don't know maybe the well maybe
the well genius idea number two what you
see out there these out there he's
definitely out there what are you doing
there dog
fine I'll go upstairs check that out
Oh bro don't you follow me no follow me
wrong maybe I need to learn him here all
right come here brah brah
come here brah brah brah you need to
walk around okay about being that
specific bear bear bear bear bear bear
okay okay
I got it I got it Burberry Burberry
blueberries blueberries
oh man I love blueberries and
strawberries too okay tell em there's a
big a blade extents out two cones base
what
why
all right take this
and the spiral age
[Music]
and we
I I don't even know anymore I need a
human heart girl tell me woman where is
he anyway and the [ __ ] did he go up is
he doing like photo look at the light
it's so beautiful I forget to like us
I love lights is I got insight oh that's
beautiful
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do anyway I'm
gonna end it here hope you bros enjoyed
[ __ ] alright I do like I don't even know
anymore
let's see freakin did something had on
bro your suck bro poop okay okay okay
he's after me Oh Oh bro Wow that's my
[ __ ] leg you hit right there oh okay
maybe now maybe now we're good this
again I need your heart bro all right
anyway oh there he is
alright anyway I'm gonna do so hope you
guys enjoyed like a favorite if you did
and subscribe if you haven't already and
that's pretty much it
[Music]